mine is an app you can find it on
browser on laptop as well called Arlo
a-i-r-a-l-o which is for cellular data
overseas and it is the easiest
most reliable approach that I found to
cellular data overseas so if you're
going to any country you can buy a
cellular data plan even if for instance
in my case Verizon may not support I can
help you here I got a better solution
than this but go ahead
all right well I can't wait to hear okay
you know in case of Verizon like yeah
they want to upgrade you in quotation
marks all the time to like an unlimited
data plan but
the cost question is open for me so I've
used erlo which I have been very happy
with up to this point in time so what's
your better alternative so here's
something that people most people don't
know is that
iPhones in particular and I believe
Android phones as well they can support
multiple Sims and at this at this point
in time it's they're called esims
because you don't actually need a SIM
card so airlose and esim yeah okay so
Google Phi
is just insane because
internationally they give you coverage
in just so many countries I don't have
the exact number but I put on a
secondary plan so there's two things
that this helps you with
my main plan is Verizon and I use that
for data because I have good 5G I use it
for my main phone number no sorry I
don't use my phone number I use it for
data I use my phone number at Google fi
because it's protected by two-factor
authentication all crazy security of
Google fi so Sim swaps are a very you
know they just can't happen because
there's not not a person a call to trick
into doing a Sim swap you have to
actually log in with your Google account
so use that Google fi is your main
number change the data to go to Verizon
so you get the good data package because
you can do this so walk me through this
just to back up so I have a Verizon
account
okay what do I do okay so you want to
transfer your number to Google fi how do
you do that you call Google fi on the on
the website we'll walk you through it
now Google find is not gonna get not
going to give you the best data so what
you then do is you say Okay Verizon I
love you but you're going to be my data
only plan and they charge like 20 a
month or something for it it's data only
okay so that's your esim that is data
only and then in the settings you say
hey where do you want to get your data
from and you say I want to get it from
Verizon and then you got the 5G Network
in the United States you're good to go
right and then your security of your
main phone number is locked down by
Google fi so that's the most secure
place that you can have it then when you
go abroad because Google fi has all of
these International connections it's
like over 200
destinations they say they have coverage
on it's insanely cheap like their data
plans are the cheapest there are out
there then you go into your phone
settings and say switch my data from
Verizon to Google fi so now your Google
file all the time when you're
International and one phone you don't
have to switch phones or anything and so
I have this like little two bar thing
that goes on they show you two bars on
your phone when you when you do both of
the plans so it's it's great I love it
boom so what is the infrastructure of
Google fine how are they providing that
data they use multiple providers but
it's mainly T-Mobile in the United
States but it says that all plans
include US Canada and Mexico unlimited
plans and flex of plans data in 200 plus
International destinations plus 5G and
select countries
and their 5G country list just keeps
growing and growing it's it's great man
every time I've ever flyed anywhere
International I just turn on Google fi
and I get like the highest speed it's
fantastic and it's so inexpensive
amazing I'm on it all right
so I'm taking notes too folks